hey guys it's Tuesday October 18th I'm
Mary and what a day it is for gamespot
news we're having a party because today
we found out that red dead redemption to
is going to come out
yes it was revealed today that we are
getting a new Red Dead game and it's
titled red dead redemption to finally
putting to rest that age-old argument
about whether or not would be red dead 3
or red dead too it's red dead to deal
with it after offering some nice teasers
earlier this week rockstar games has now
officially announced red dead redemption
to the game is coming out in fall 2017
for ps4 and xbox one pc was not
mentioned a trailer will be released at
11am this Thursday October 20th in a
statement Rockstar exclaimed that red
dead redemption to is an epic tale of
life in America's on forgiving heartland
the game's vast and Atmospheric world
will also provide the foundation for a
brand new online multiplayer experience
rockstar has not offered any specifics
on red dead redemption tues gameplay but
the last line is particularly
interesting considering a domain name
for red dead online was recently
discovered grand theft auto 5 s
multiplayer mode GTA online has brought
in a boatload of cash it seems likely
the first red dead redemption had
multiplayer but this one seems like it's
going to go further the image above
shows seven different characters who are
all still somewhat blurry but are more
in focus than they were in the last
teaser they're all wielding weapons like
pistols and long rifles the man standing
in front and center looks like he's
going to be the protagonist but this
isn't confirmed we're gonna have more on
this story as it develops which will
most likely be Thursday as if today
wasn't already great for gamers we found
out that battlefield one is getting a
release date for the full game for
everyone that might sound a little
confusing so here's a full breakdown
battlefield one officially launches on
october 21st now some of you guys have
already been playing the play first
trial that contains a limited selection
of the game single-player and
multiplayer content that launched on
October 13th for EA origin access
subscribers EA access is available on
the xbox one and origin access is the
subscription services pc version there's
no EA access available for ps4 right now
however people who buy the $80 early and
Lister edition of battlefield one can
start playing the full game today
October 18th like the full game next
week the early and lister edition
unlocks at midnight this premium version
of battlefield one which also comes with
extra digital content is available on
ps4 xbox one and pc the ongoing first
play trial version of battlefield one
contains five maps and four modes for
multiplayer along with single player
missions storm of steel and through the
mud and blood when the early and lister
Edition comes out tomorrow the remaining
multiplayer maps and modes will be
available for first play trial members
however the early access period is
limited to 10 hours so if you've reached
the limit by October 18th you'll need to
buy the game to play those new maps and
modes EA origin access members save ten
percent on all digital content knocking
down the base game to 54 bucks the early
edition to 72 bucks and the ultimate
addition to a hundred and seventeen
dollars the ultimate edition is the only
version of the game to include it's
fifty dollar premium pass which comes
with four expansion packs additionally
premium pass owners will have access to
DLC maps two weeks before people who buy
it standalone that was just like star
wars battlefront battlefield ones first
DLC map is called Giants shadow it's
free for everyone and comes out in
December the game's first premium pass
expansion beautifully titled they shall
not pass comes out March 2017 finally a
Pokemon Sun and Moon demo just came out
it's out today and it's already been day
to mind for some juicy information I
told you it was a good day for gamers
according to the date of mine there's
800 Pokemon in sun and moon i'm not
going to get into spoilers i'm not gonna
be mentioning any specifics here but if
you really want to know you can go to
gamespot com where we have a list of all
the videos and all the spoiled pokemon
in the Pokemon Sun and Moon demo which
is available on the eshop now by the way
players will have greninja on the roster
it can become ash greninja and you can
transfer it to the full game ash
greninja was previously seen alongside
ash in the Pokemon series XYZ animated
TV show Pokemon Sun and Moon are
scheduled to come out November
eighteenth they are the first new games
in the main line series since Pokemon
goes record-setting released in July
whether this will translate to stronger
sales of the traditional Pokemon games
will be interesting to see Nintendo
recently announced that 2d sales surged
five hundred percent due to excitement
for Pokemon we're actually live
streaming the Pokemon Sun and Moon demo
on gamespot YouTube and twitch right
about now so you're gonna want to check
that out and that's pretty much it
nothing's gonna top those three stories
so the party's over